so this concludes our course on  blockchain and cryptocurrency we hope  you've enjoyed this journey of unpacking  and understanding some of the major  components of the space including its  many challenges and opportunities for  innovation  in the larger picture blockchain  technologies are still fairly new and  the space is constantly evolving some of  the applications we identified for today  might be completely different tomorrow  and so forth the rate of innovation is  really high but that's exactly why the  space is so exciting regardless of where  the technology goes its potential to  impact our lives is quite high we hope  you've enjoyed your time with us and can  now evaluate for yourself the potential  for this technology so thank you and we  look forward to seeing you in one of our  future courses thank you all very much  for joining us